all right Ryan we're about to give these
folks right now it might be my favorite
live event that we've ever done well
dude it in our defense man Canada always
always usually has pretty awesome events
always usually does always usually I
agree and so but Edmonton there was just
something about this event was at the
culmination or six cities up there and
it was just everything was was firing on
all cylinders as they say and man I just
felt really good about it and in fact it
I felt so good about it's been a problem
after that because I was I found myself
especially initially comparing
everything after that like how can I
make it just as good at the end of all
the other events after the Canada Wave
you're like dude that was not as good as
the Canada Way so before we dive into
that though a couple of really exciting
announcements we just announced the
Australia and New Zealand tour so we're
we're headed over to that side of the
world in March you can find all the
tickets and information over at our
website the minimalists calm and just
click on the tour button you'll find the
four cities Brisbane Melbourne Sydney
and Oakland and men I will tell you this
most of our events in the United States
and Canada are selling out and our
audience in Australia is even bigger so
all four of these will sell out if you
want tickets please go grab those right
now we're also finishing up the rest of
the North American tour we're going to
be in Ohio Texas Tennessee Washington DC
Georgia Florida Michigan and Wisconsin
we have ten more stops this year and so
you can find all the details of that les
is now calm i Ryan I hope they enjoy
this outstanding episode of the
minimalist podcast live they usually
always do man how do you know this look
at our ratings enjoy the show
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without me
[Music]
hey y'all let's record a podcast live
from the University of Alberta
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists live in Edmonton
while you all are the best thank you so
much we got a microphone set up for you
right over here so now is a good time
instead of calling up as what we usually
do but if you called us right now we
wouldn't be able to answer and so you
can just step on up to the mic well
answer some questions and I brought a
bag of answers can I borrow some of
those perfect
how did what's your name hi I'm Roberta
hey Roberta hi
are you from I am from a tiny little
hamlet called Follis so it's west of
Emmett and on your way to Jasper okay so
blink you'll miss it
first of all I'm so glad you guys are
here I feel like you're my Big Brother's
like only like a year or two so don't
feel too bad but I honestly have to tell
you that your documentary changed my
life and you might not be comfortable
with that praise but it really did I
suffered horribly with postpartum
depression tough for both of my children
and I don't know how your documentary
caught my attention on Netflix but it
did and so I watched it and instantly I
was like this is what I need and I went
crazy and I was getting rid of stuff
left right and center and the more I got
rid of the better I felt and every time
I box something up or took it out of the
house it was like a weight was lifted
off my shoulders and it was amazing and
I am so grateful for that I tell
everyone about you I dragged my friend
here she had to sit back by herself
because I'm up in the VIP
[Music]
[Applause]
what's your friend's name Gillian
Gillian welcome to our cult sorry is the
joke for those of us very just won't be
passing out any kool-aid later thank you
for that for that praise I really
appreciate it and I'm grateful that
we're able to make a difference yeah and
I gotta say it like that feels the same
every single time it's funny because
when I look back like all the things
that I used to look forward to like you
know a bigger promotion or a bigger
paycheck or you know an upgrade or a new
car or you know buying a house whatever
it was all those things were very
ephemeral but like this like that
compliment it feels the same every
single time so thank you very much
you're welcome so I do have an actual
question actually - first of all Ryan -
just straighten your hair tonight yes
ladies and gentlemen jessica lynn
williams is around here somewhere
she occasionally handles our social
media as well yeah she's actually live
tweeting tonight so if any of you have
Twitter or the other socials we're at
the minimalists on all of those and she
like shares all of our pithy or
obnoxious answers so what's your second
question my second question is for you
primarily Josh I know you've been doing
the ketogenic diet yeah and I have been
looking into it and I'm at a loss of
where to start I kind of OCD need a
little bit more direction as to what I
should eat or should avoid or you know
kind of some rules to start yes consult
your doctor before getting any health
advice from a guy who doesn't understand
much about diet
so for those of you who haven't listened
I recently found I had a lot of issues
but I have mercury poisoning and that's
the reason I'm embarking on something
called a ketogenic diet which is a
really high fat diet
it's 75 percent fat 20% protein and with
five percent carbs somewhere around
there and which is it sounds also I'm
eat that all day and it's really hard
you're like mmm macadamia nuts again for
dinner and a cup of olive oil maybe not
so tasty yeah yeah know what but it
really feels like food is fuel but I've
experienced a few things great side
effects that I didn't intend although I
know I've heard this from other people
so first off the the the things that I'm
doing I can tell you what I'm doing I
can't tell you what you should do I act
my my macronutrients on an app called
MyFitnessPal and yeah I have no
affiliation with them whatsoever it's
just my partner Rebecca is a dietitian
and she she runs a great website called
minimal wellness comm and she is you
know I've been her guinea pig but in a
good way she I just feel really grateful
cuz I have someone who's really
supportive and also understanding but
what I can do with with this diet is is
detox from this mercury poisoning that I
have that's the main objective but I'm
leaner than I've ever been which has
been a great benefit but but then also I
have experienced this and Ryan's been
doing it while we're on the road as well
just to be really supportive mental
clarity can you talk - they mean don't
know if you've experienced the same
thing but to me like I've I've felt this
this clarity I didn't mean that it'd be
funny but I as soon as I said it I
realized no it is true it's like well
here's how I look at it diet it's like
every decision you make with your diet
it has like this little bit of an
incremental effect on your overall
health and especially how you feel
mentally how you feel physically and
I'll say with the ketogenic diet um like
I haven't had I haven't had any like
cupcakes or anything in the last few
weeks and look I don't eat a lot of
cupcakes but my partner Mariah
Shiki cupcakes for breakfast lunch and
dinner and like never gained a pound so
yeah and I like totally admire like this
metabolism that she has but like she
will bring him home every once a while
I'm like oh it's just one cupcake I
always go and I'll tell you what it's so
not eating the sugar cuz that's really
kind of the main thing I realized it's
like oh wow like I am eating an
extremely less amount of sugar now that
I'm doing this ketogenic diet so I think
cutting sugar out which literally like
they have done Studies on this and it
will it literally kills you it's slowly
it's it's it is it is something that you
grab like a can of coke and it's got 30
grams of sugar I'm probably probably 28
grams of sugar or something around there
an average man should have only about 30
grams of sugar in a day and especially
in America like the average is well over
that so I've noticed that cutting out
sugar helps but yes like having your
body burn fat definitely helps give a
little bit more clarity and just eating
some like wholesome like really basic
foods like when we went to lunch earlier
we were at the store and and it was a
grocery store and we literally like
bought a couple rib eyes and like have
them grill them up and then we just ate
them like no seasoning no salt no
nothing and it was delicious but I think
when you know when you eat wholesome
foods that without the sauces and the
sugar is in the
salt you know and all the all the
additives I think that has a little bit
to do with the mental clarity as well so
I I would say I'm gonna hungry anymore
yeah they're sure I mean you get to a
point where you're like okay it's time
to eat it's time to put fuel in this
meat vehicle that I'm walking around
what and and you sort of treat it that
way and it's like oh well my
macronutrient ratio is this I need to
make sure I get an adequate amount of
fat but this it's virtually no carbs you
learned that I mean so it's fewer than
25 grams of carbs a day which is which
goes really quick which is essentially
zero right
a few resources for you go if you
haven't listened to it already there's
there's a doctor named Dom D'Agostino
and he is like a keto expert find the
podcast he did with Rhonda Patrick yeah
she's she's also a genius and you'll
have to like stop and take notes but
it'll be really helpful and then they'll
give you some guidance for sure okay
perfect thank you thank you thanks for
the question
[Applause]
hi Josh Ron how do my name's Tim I'm
from bar hood area
welcome I I just added some a question I
need some advice
I have a family that likes to hoard
antiques and family heirlooms and that
kind of stuff and since I'm the oldest
male in my family I get to inherit
everything which I don't want at all
it's furniture books photographs lots of
family memorabilia that's been in there
for a hundred years or so so who are you
inheriting this from my father's side
and my mother's side okay when you say
side I mean it sounds to me they're like
just heaps of family members who are
heaping hoards of sentimental items on
to you pretty much okay I don't doubt it
I'm just trying to understand that the
problem so how have you communicated
this huh how have you communicated your
your desire to not have these not to be
buried in their stuff i I've had
conversations with my mother and I said
you know if you could give this my
sister that would be great perfect
because I think ill problem solved there
but my dad it's cuz I'm the male with
the surname so I have to have it to
continue it on in the family which I
really don't want and I've kind of
trying to ease it in getting him into
this but it's not going very well last
night we were in Calgary and we were we
do this hug line book signing line out
after the fact and this lady came up to
me and she goes I really want to talk to
you about your pencil dick
[Music]
and I was like how does she know you got
a pencil dick and when she said I said I
looked at her seriously I said what
and she goes it's okay I'm an English
teacher I don't know if you're confused
right now but in that moment I felt
compelled and my first instinct was how
do I prove to this woman I don't have a
pencil dick and of course I'm thinking
that there's a line of people and if I
were to prove it somehow I would be
arrested this evening so I had to figure
out what she was talking about and it
really meant that I need to do a better
job of listening and also communicating
with her and what she actually said was
I need to talk to you about your pencil
grip I am an English teacher and you're
holding your pencil and correctly is
what she meant and so
what I had to do was work harder to
better understand what she was trying to
say and with your father what is he
actually trying to communicate because
there's a thing and you may not be able
to answer this right now but it's
something you're gonna have to figure
out why does he want to pass these on to
you because saying no to him is going to
be something you can do saying no to him
without hurting his feelings is gonna be
something that's a little bit more
intricate and I think it's going to
involve really understanding not what he
wants but why he wants to pass that on
to you the way I look at it as I think
he wants the legacy to continue the
family legacy of these items that's
still the what though it's not the why
and I think we keep getting deeper well
we'll get a few more layers of what or
how but eventually we'll get to the why
and and and part of this fear of death I
think part of it is is not understanding
that on a long enough timeline
everything is ephemeral so like all of
these sentimental items you when the Sun
burns out they all go away anyway right
and at some point before then they also
become less relevant they're already not
relevant to you and so you also once you
are able to understand his why you need
to find a way to also communicate your
why to him and in a way that he can
understand it not in a way that you
would want to hear it but in a way that
that he would want to hear it yeah the
only thing I would add to that is you
are the legacy it's not the stuff
so I you know how can you how can you
show your father that that that it's not
about you know hanging on to a bunch of
accoutrements and furniture and really I
mean if it's I'm just imagining someone
giving me like a really old like record
player like hey your grandpa had this I
would just feel like oh this is great
this is really cool but I'm not cool
enough to listen to records so I'll
probably find someone who who did listen
to records and I would try and add value
to someone else's life through that that
that particular item yeah having that
conversation is definitely gonna be
difficult with your dad but finding that
where he's coming from the why to and
having him understand where you're
coming from the why to like that is
ultimately what's gonna help you maybe
not have like a perfect scenario but but
maybe something that's more ideal for
the both of you thank you guys thanks
brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
honey what's your name I'm Megan Parker
Quinn Megan I am a striving minimalist
I've recently gone from a three-bedroom
house to a one-room apartment
congrat two kids thank you it's very
fresh start feeling it's impressive with
two kids yes
yeah we did a packing party for the kids
Bravo that's instead of going through
all the emotional what ages there are
eight and five they're pretty probably
pretty excited about that
yeah oh it's a whole new adventure for
them yeah no III mean I people like
scoff at that like verbally which tells
me more about you and I can tell you the
kids they love getting rid of [ __ ] once
you've been still once you've instilled
that habit into them sometimes you can't
stomp on them I'm like wait that's
that's mine why are you getting annoyed
stop and ellas like run around what's
easy to get rid of your stuff let's
donated yeah there's been a lot of any
empty recycle like receptacle has now
been full like they put stuff in there
now because they're like it's a donation
bin and like no that's our laundry
basket okay but I find myself after
getting rid of so many things that I'm
actually really surprised about how I'm
not really missing as much as I thought
I was going to and I was wondering if
you guys found after your minimalism
adventure if there was something that
you did that you were surprised missing
or not missing man I remember how upset
Josh was when he was finally missing his
Faberge egg collection
No you know people have collections of
frat Faberge eggs I think so I thought
that was like you bought one I'm gonna
be honest I don't know anything about
Faberge eggs
you know no I mean the short answer is
no anything I got rid of especially the
just in case items like oh man so we
worked for a telecommunications company
I had two ton of cell phones that I
would get I try out and then like
working for the company they let you
keep it
and you know when that phone was brand
new it was like 500 bucks and I would
put that in a drawer because I'm like
whoa this is worth $500 I'm not gonna
like just throw it away maybe I can give
it away to someone so forth and so on or
maybe I can sell it and I remember going
through everything after the packing
party and they came across like you know
five or six cell phones and in my head
I'm like and this is this is worth like
you know a couple thousand dollars and
well first I realized like wait a minute
these cell phones are a couple years old
there's no way I'm ever gonna get the
original retail value out of the cell
phone and if I tried to sell them I like
looked on eBay to see what some of the
phones were selling for and they weren't
selling for even $50 so at that point I
kind of looked at this stuff and I'm
like yeah most of this is some cost like
even though I've invested you know tens
of thousands of dollars into all of this
stuff that was sitting in my living room
none of it I can never get that that
that back so I kind of had to look at it
like you it was a sunk cost and you know
even like the small stuff um little
cables that came with the phones or they
came with a certain piece of technology
that I got or like the like the amount
of warranties and like boxes I had from
stuff that I had purchased it was it was
astounding you're gonna close it I
remember the we were doing
a closet of empty boxes that used to
have I mean there was like the the
coffins yes first the coffins of my
coffin yeah and I'm like what but like
twin geing though like oh man I don't
want to throw that warranty way I don't
want to throw that box away or I don't
want to throw that extra part away but
then I'm like do I live in the 21st
century like this stuff is it's pretty
accessible like I don't have to hold on
to all of all of these things and I and
I think that's why a lot of people
including myself we hang on to a lot of
stuff but it does go back to that that
just in case or maybe there's there's
this perceived value that that I had
over it but when I finally got the the
leverage to let go of all of that stuff
like I really haven't ever looked back
and thought man why did I get rid of you
know X Y & Z I wish I had like a really
sexy answer for that question
but but I I don't because at the end of
the day the things I have in my life now
like they do serve a purpose they they
bring me joy where I couldn't say that
about myself seven years ago I was
earlier today I was walking down to the
North Saskatchewan River and
[Music]
I was at the beach I got lost on the
trails back there and I was like oh [ __ ]
like they're gonna be looking for me at
nine o'clock tonight I was just like
hiking these random trails but I was
walking on my way there I I was walking
through campus and I saw a bunch of kids
who were playing cricket and so I
stopped and and I just stood there
mesmerized because it's sort of like
American baseball right but it's not at
all if there's a ball and a stick
involved and that seems to be the extent
of it but it was so foreign to me when
I'm want and I'm just I'm mesmerized by
because it seems so strange and like I
could never figure it out but although
clearly you once you once you start
playing and participating you start
understanding the game a lot more and I
found for me that minimalism was really
similar like it seems so extreme or so
foreign or like I could be an observer
of this really easily but participating
in it seems impossible but once I
started participating in it I'm like I
get the hang of this this is no problem
and so once I got that momentum I felt
like I almost got good at minimalism in
a way and because I for me it didn't
just you know I was talking about it
earlier during the talk that we gave it
wasn't just about the stuff right it was
about all of the things beyond the stuff
and and really the questions that
started coming out does this add value
to my life and asking that so many times
that it became less of an intellectual
exercise and more of this sort of
emotion that you feel like when you look
at something you can kind of know like
yeah if I'm being honest to myself
that's it's not really adding value to
my life can I ask you do you or your
kids like do you have anything that you
got rid of and you're like oh [ __ ] I
can't believe we got rid of that no and
I think that's what surprises me the
most that I've been slowly minimalizing
for like over six months and I don't I
don't miss any of it like at all which
really sir
prizes me so it's funny because I'm like
the one time you're talking about it
earlier like like [ __ ] like comforted
my potato masher now Mises some mashed
potatoes like I still have this really
nice mixer that I don't ever use I can
use for that so it's just yeah it just
doesn't I don't miss anything
that you know what's funny that is
that's a really good point cuz I have
discovered that to like with with Mariah
I don't think like she wouldn't call
herself a minimalist hmm I mean don't
tell her what she's totally a minimalist
but like when I first met her she had
like a ton of shoes and like a ton of
stuff when we moved in together I never
told her that that she had to get rid of
anything I never asked her to get rid of
anything but she out of respect for me
and because she is so supportive and and
she appreciates Who I am
she you know kind of challenged herself
to see what she could kind of let go of
and yeah she found out like oh I've got
like three DVD players and two of them
don't work and why do I have a DVD
player anyway yeah so should I get rid
of that stuff but to your point of there
were there was some like a potato masher
that she got that she had but then she's
like oh wait a minute I also have this
like the KitchenAid mixer type yes it
does I know from experience and it's
like IDO it was just once Josh
those mashed potatoes didn't mean
anything but yeah it's a mate it's
amazing how you you find new uses for
things when went when you when you start
to simplify a little bit yeah thanks for
the question
really appreciate it proud of you before
before we move on
for those of you listening to this at
home if you have a comment or tip for
anyone who is asking questions today you
can give us a call
leave us a voice message at four zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or you can send a voice memo right from
your phone a podcast at the minimalists
comm it's really my favorite part of the
shows when Ryan and I stop talking and
we actually get to listen to what other
people's tips are for the people who are
asking questions and and I learned so
much from it and then I can sort of just
steal and repurpose their answers later
so thank you for that
Ryan what time is it
it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round where we
usually answer your questions from
social media so Jess go get my phone I'm
kidding
that would be really weird if we were
just up here on our phone answering
questions we won't do that let's answer
your question so we usually try to do
this on Twitter Instagram Facebook at
the minimalists but we do with a pithy
less than 140 character response we call
them minimal Maxim's because it sounds
more impressive than simple ramblings or
something in fact Jessica started a
little side website for us it collects
all of our quotes and there's probably
close to a thousand there by now it's
called minimal Maxim's calm so you can a
lot of people are putting that as their
I forgot the name of this again Ryan
home screen no it's not is that it I
love technology
it's it's it's a home page home page
thank you
the Internet you guys heard of it I love
the Internet I remember we first started
our website and like I had no clue about
anything I couldn't spell HTML and and
like we're trying to cobble this website
together it's late 2010 and I just call
Ryan one day after like three weeks it
was his idea to like hey I'd start
putting some of these essays up online
we didn't even know it was called a blog
and I just call him one dammit my man
[ __ ] this he's like what are you talking
what was wrong he's like I'm done we're
not this isn't gonna happen and he
thought I was calling about something to
work because we worked at the same
company together I'm like I can't figure
out how to start our website
it's the reason it looks so simple now
is because like we couldn't figure out
how to make it any more complex anyway
we made it even more simple website
called minimal Maxim's calm and a lot of
people put it as our homepage now
because every time a refresh is like
it's a new sort of pithy thing that is
not like hopefully not trite or or vapid
which a lot of quotes that are out there
today seem to be they hopefully what we
provide is a bit more practical so maybe
we can give you a practical answer we'll
ramble on a bit but we'll try to wrap it
up with 140 characters my name is Hugh I
live with my boyfriend and he bought his
townhouse right when his parents were
getting divorced so a lot of the stuff
from his parents house ended up in his
house and then when I moved in with him
my mom was like yeah you're out of our
house and all my stuff that was at her
house ended up in our house and last
year when the Fort McMurray fires were
happening we sat down and asked
ourselves like if we had to leave our
house within like 30 minutes what would
we grab and the only things we could
think of was our three cats and this
custom Bobby Orr's flying goal painting
that I got them and so then we kind of
started we like founder documentary and
I've been listening your podcast and we
slowly started to minimalize a lot of
our stuff and then his mom was laid off
and moved in with us and all of her
stuff from her apartment is now in our
house this is nice this is like the the
basis of a great sitcom right I want to
watch it so my question really is how do
we navigate minimizing stuff with like
without offending the people that like
dump their stuff on us because before it
was easy cuz when she wasn't living with
us we could like oh this came from your
parents house it's just like toss she's
not there but now when I was doing it
before I was like taking like a lot of
it's like kitchen stuff and she's like
oh that was my grandmother's and I gave
that to so-and-so when he moved in here
and it's like yeah but we haven't
touched it in seven years so can you
like get it out the door like it's
easier when she wasn't there so it's
kind of like if you don't live with
somebody who like adopts this minimalist
lifestyle how is it hot like how do you
navigate getting rid of stuff that's
like joint stuff I guess like I can't
just go through her room and get rid of
her stuff but
but it's like joint house stuff does
that make sense
quick hundred forty characters go Ryan
no is uh is fish here tonight where you
at brother
did you make it here oh he didn't so
there's a bit maybe Oh nope alright I
see one hit hand maybe they were like
timid anyway he's a journalist for the
Edmonton Journal and a couple years ago
December 2015
he played our 30-day minimalism game and
documented in the Edmonton Journal and
he we just an interview with him last
week and it came out yesterday I think
and he asked great questions and he's
really good at writing about this in a
way they captured the Hal to but also
the emotional essence of the process and
the reason Ryan and I started this this
30-day minimalism game for those of you
who aren't acquainted with it it's the
minimalists calm slash game here's how
it works really quickly you partner up
with someone this is why it made sense
to me so you partner up someone else who
wants to give away everything wants to
get rid of some stuff over the course of
a month and most of us have no idea
where to start that's kind of where you
are right now I have no idea where to
start I got all this stuff I'm inundated
with stuff and it's overwhelming so it's
sort of the paradox of choice I'm not
gonna make any choice I'm not gonna
decide I'm not gonna start and so you
partner up with someone friend family
member co-worker enemy just someone
who's willing to get rid of some stuff
and over the course a month you're going
to get rid of stuff first day of the
month eat get rid of one item second day
the month two items third day the month
three items starts off really easy
really slow to get you that momentum you
need by mid mid month it starts to get
more difficult now fish wherever he is
hiding here in the crowd tonight he he
documented this in photos every single
day over the course of of 31 days so you
see like this stuff piling up around him
as he's getting rid of of these things
accumulating these things and you
realize like oh
crap on day 15 it gets a lot harder I
figure out of 15 items which isn't too
bad but tomorrow I have to get rid of 16
items and the damn for that it's 17
items whoever goes the longest wins you
all make it to the end of the month and
then you all win because you've gotten
rid of about 500 items but even more
important you've started to build this
muscle of letting go and so oh there's
my pithy answer for you it's look I'm
tweeting in my head right now composing
letting go is a muscle
indeed oh man um you know bonus points
it's good you know Shawn just edit that
part out let's try this again
alright here's my Pippi answer for you
how about this letting go as a muscle so
flex it
man Josh that was such a good tweetable
answer yeah thanks I thought of it all
by myself
the whole time you were saying this
story the things that stood out to me
was that when you left your parents are
so happy to get rid of your [ __ ] and
then they moved them and then your mom
they've done with you I'm sorry his mom
moved in with you to bring her stuff and
all I could think is like my tweetable
answer would be it doesn't matter if
your parents live with you if it's your
house you get to make the rules
[Applause]
thank you thank you howdy I'm Laurel and
I'm from Edmonton hey Laura how many
people are behind you right now
okay I'm gonna apologize we're gonna
hold two more there but behind Laurel
and because eventually the theater will
kick us out like literally happened to
us in Vancouver two nights ago we're on
the street I'm no joke like giving out
hugs and signing books and they're like
we've got a midnight movie we have to
run sorry yeah after Laurel here but I
apologize the folks in line you will get
a hug afterward though okay I'll be
quick how do you navigate Christmases
anniversaries birthdays for your loved
ones who perhaps aren't as involved or
engaged in this lifestyle like I'm
thinking of I I draw names down with my
side of the family and my sister thinks
I'm Scrooge and that I've ruined
Christmas because of that because I
brought that in for Christmas yeah I
actually think in terms of gift-giving
what what the tendency is or at least
what we think is well no other animals
have to say no to gift-giving and
instead I say yes to the right kind of
gift-giving right and so instead of the
obligatory gift I like to give gifts on
a day that isn't an obligatory
gift-giving day so well today is
December 25th Ryan I bought you these
cufflinks hope you enjoy them what what
shiny object did you get for me that I'm
not going to use I got you couplings too
you're just giving those couplings back
to me
and instead what I'll try to do is find
something that adds value to someone
else's life and give it to them on the
day on a random day because they're not
expecting it right there the expectation
is 0 for a gift so non obligatory days
but that said I also understand that
gift-giving is sort of a cultural
imperative for a lot of people and thus
instead of saying no I'm not going to
give you a gift I'll say yes I'm
absolutely gonna give you a gift and
it's gonna be a deliberate gift it's
going I'm gonna give you an experience
and because my pet the answer is
presence is the best present I think my
tweetable answer would be when it comes
to gifts set the expectation early and
give an amazing gift so when it comes to
your family it sounds like you have set
the expectation I'm either calling you
Scrooge which is kind of [ __ ] man
because I mean honestly like if your
family loves you and they want you to be
happy like why would they put you down
no I know it's my sister she's just
joking yeah okay because she loves
buying gifts for everyone and now I've
limited her to one person I like jokes
that's good and here especially loves
passive-aggressive jokes
but but when what I have found is when I
when I give gifts now they actually are
so much better than the gifts the
obligatory gifts I used to give like now
I go out of my way to to find something
and it might be a thing or maybe it is
an experience or maybe it is a
consumable but something that that
whoever I'm giving the gift to is really
really going to appreciate it you know
what I used to do before I'd go to the
mall like two weeks before Christmas and
I'd start walking around looking for
inspiration what what an unintentional
way to give a gift to someone like to
walk around and wait till something
stands out to you I mean that is like
probably the least thoughtful way to
give a gift
so again just set the expectation early
which sounds like you've done and give
amazing gifts to the people you love
thank you thank you wait wait right
there we will get to you I promise
first we're gonna move on to our added
value segment of the show this is where
Ryan and I usually talk about something
has added value to our lives recently
but since we were here in Edmonton we
might as well talk about something in
Edmonton that adds value to our lives
Ryan what has added value to your life
recently let's see three whoa no this is
our we've done four tour stops in the
last five years in in Edmonton yeah and
I can I mean I think low key Edmonton
might be my favorite city in Canada
[Applause]
and I don't I don't say that lightly I
we've we've been all over we've been
every province except Newfoundland and
Pei and what don't say it like that well
how do I say it
Newfoundland Newfoundland oh we're
really sorry really sorry about that
[Music]
Ryan and I I don't mean to sound racist
but there are a lot of Canadians here
tonight but anyway so the very first
time we came up to Edmonton we we did a
mini Alberta tour we just did Calvary in
Edmonton and I remember this was 20
early 2013 we spoke in the largest mall
in North America West Edmonton Mall
someone just cheered for the mall it's
got a roller coaster in it yeah I think
so
it has a bookstore too and we we were
there and like I couldn't tell how many
people on like Twitter and Facebook
really you hypocrites you're gonna speak
in the largest mall and I'm
and I'm like where do you want me to go
speak it like Buddhist monastery you
guys need to get rid of your stuff
Ryan these monks they have so many robes
no I'd rather much much rather put my
message up against you this sort of
rapaciousness of overindulgent
consumption and let people decide for
themselves like we don't want to convert
anyone to minimalism but you put this
message next to that and let people
choose for themselves but after that we
we've done two stops or the last two
stops four and Audrey's books yeah
the those have been some of the best
events that Josh and I have ever had
not just because like it's a great staff
it's a great book store and like
supporting an independent bookstore to
me it means a lot there are play there
are huge major cities like Dallas Texas
where there is not one independent book
shop and that's really sad and in my
opinion and you know not just others big
cities like Regina
but any independent places I just I love
the support they don't I know I don't
know why they're laughing it's really
sad no I and no they've just been a
couple great great great tour stops um
the first time someone had ever come up
to us and they were like man I don't
even read books I've never read a book
in my life but I heard you guys talking
on the radio and I'm here and I'm gonna
read your book and like that's one of
the biggest compliments that anyone can
give us as far as I'm concerned so yeah
Audrey's books is definitely awesome if
you don't know about I go check it out
and support your your local mom-and-pop
places yeah I think that you know
especially with with the the sort of
Internet expansion of Amazon everything
else and I don't think there's anything
wrong with with with Amazon and and
there's nothing inherently wrong with
Amazon or corporations I think we need
community spaces like that and they
provide a service that we can take
advantage of and we can support
I was so what's been adding value to my
life here there's a bunch of stuff but
but I'll tell you that was the one thing
that stands out that I keep going back
to every time I come here is there's a
restaurant called nourish yeah and I was
over there today and man like even
though I'm on this keto diet and it's a
vegan restaurant which vegan and keto
just don't go together
but they made it work and it was so
amazing
and so I'm grateful that they're here I
mean that's one of the reasons I really
love Edmonton I feel like it's a city
much like many of the other cities that
I love in North America places like Salt
Lake City or Tucson or st. Petersburg
like these cities you wouldn't you
wouldn't think of first as like the the
world-class city but they they have
outsized culture for the size of their
city so Bravo for that haven't
let's move on real quick to right here
right now so we're talking about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
if you couldn't tell we're on tour right
now I know right
in Canada has been extra supportive
we've sold out all of our Canada tour
stops as our last tour stop in Canada
thank you so much
[Applause]
if you're in the United States we've got
40 cities total this year lessons
now.com
we're going to a bunch of different
cities a lot of those are already sold
out one city that isn't sold out though
is Houston and there's an obvious reason
for that I'm sure you all have seen
what's going on in Houston lately with
the floods over a hundred thousand
houses have have been devastated and
it's going to take years to rebuild the
homes and and that city for folks and
Ryan and I one of the reasons we do what
we do is so we can try to contribute
beyond ourselves as much as we can and
so we've we're helping a we've partnered
up with a charity called GlobalGiving
and we found three ways that you all can
contribute to that as well what
GlobalGiving does is 100% of the the
proceeds go directly to the Relief Fund
it's called the hurricane Harvey Relief
Fund and it's you've two uses one is the
immediate sort of needs and the
immediate care so first aid first
responders stuff like that but then also
an equally important long-term is the
rebuilding effort so yeah we can't just
go help people and then all of a sudden
if you're gone and they have nothing to
rebuild with and so they're they're sort
of looking at both ends and I was really
impressed by that this charity was
recommended by the Houston Chronicle but
also by Charity Navigator they're
extremely reputable charity and so we
decided to partner up with them and
we're doing an event there on November
5th so if you listen to us at home you
get a chance to come down to that a
hundred percent of the profits from that
are going to the hurricane Harvey Relief
Fund if you can't make it to that event
you can also donate directly you can go
to the minimalists comm slash Harvey and
we just have a link to the GlobalGiving
site it doesn't none of it goes through
us or to us or anything like that it
goes straight to global giving so we're
on tour in the next year we're gonna go
Australia New Zealand we're gonna
announce those dates really soon over
less is now.com and after that who knows
just make sure you're on our email list
over at the minimalists calm and we'll
always announce it they're the people we
announced it to first though are the
folks who support us on patreon every
week now Ryan and I have been doing a
what we do the minimalist podcast the
right
podcast that shows up in your podcast
feed wherever you listen to podcast but
also in that same podcast feed you can
get the minimalists private podcast we
do a separate podcast the day after it
comes out the day after the regular
podcast exclusively for the people were
supporting our podcast because Ryan and
I don't do advertisements we have one of
the biggest podcast in the world and
it's a really strange thing to say but
we refuse to do advertisements just
because it doesn't align with our
personal values and so we need your help
we're building we're moving to Los
Angeles this month we're building a
podcast and film studio and the only way
we can do that is with your help and so
if you want to contribute on a per
episode basis you can do so over at the
minimalists comm just click on donate
and that will help us build this podcast
and film studio but also gives you a
bunch of freebies well you get the whole
back catalogue of all the private
podcasts and live streams that we do
every single month and then access to
early tickets to any event that we're
doing as well and your support keeps the
podcast 100% advertisement free because
advertisements suck
[Music]
and so real quick right now what I'd
like to do is a patreon only private
podcast live in Edmonton just to finish
up here on on right here right now we
are gonna be right here right now in 20
minutes we'll be out in the lobby or so
as one of minutes or so with this she'll
hugs signed books if you if you want to
buy a book but you didn't bring your
wallet or you just can't afford one
we're happy to buy one it's on us so if
you if you want to walk away with one
tonight let us buy one for you thanks I
think a couple people before before we
get out of here tonight while we're on
the road we have Jessica with us she
does social media and French braids
Ryan's hair said you'd never bring that
up and the mashed potatoes man that was
so long ago man you hold it over my head
man
how could you know I we have a bunch of
other people on the road with us we have
a tour manager a road manager we have a
podcast producer a podcast editor over
our website editor all wrapped up into
one outstanding human being he's our
operations guy and all-around wonderful
person ladies and gentleman podcast Sean
is hiding in the shadows up there
[Applause]
[Music]
we are great for you grateful for you my
friend thank you for being here and for
making everything that we do a lot
better and I want to thank the Horowitz
Theatre for having us here tonight what
a great place right
[Music]
[Applause]
see the problem is we couldn't cram like
seven or eight hundred people into
Audry's books anymore so this was our
next alternative we'll get back there at
some point would you like a tweet up
there or something
and but last and most important I want
to thank I want to thank you
we know you spent some money to get in
here tonight and that's great because it
allows us to have a nice venue and
higher security and staff and and have
Sean and Jess on the road with us and we
really appreciate that but more
important you gave up your two most
precious resources it wasn't money it
was time and attention and we want to
thank you for that and if you leave here
tonight with just one message actually
two messages if you get one of our books
minimize it afterward you probably don't
need to hold on to it let it collect
dust on the shelf but the other message
is more important than that and it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works
thank you Edmondson you guys have been
awesome
[Applause]
hi Josh and Ryan my name is Rachel I'm
calling from LA first of all welcome to
LA we love hope you love it here just as
much as we do I just wanted to call in
and give some feedbacks the young lady
on one of your live shows asking about
getting through college debt-free I made
it through college debt-free with two
bachelor's degrees and it is totally
possible and very much very much worth
it I hear so many stories from everyone
around me about what they can't do or
the jobs they don't enjoy but can't
leave because they're tied to income to
sustain a college debt payments in your
question it did sound like you're asking
about having the full tuition amount in
the bank before starting school while
that would totally be ideal don't forget
you have the time while you're in school
to work in Paige you go for example at
my college we were allowed to make three
payments a semester to kind of break up
that expense so don't forget there are
so many ways to save money on the normal
college expenses and earn money as you
go good luck I know you can do it and it
is very much worth it
hi Josh and Ryan this is Jennifer from
upstate New York I am a long time
listener and I find a lot of value in
what you're doing so thank you I wanted
to speak to all the parents who called
in looking for advice
with how to handle their children and
all of those things I have two children
under the age of 10 and I think the
first thing is what you have already
shared is to be a really good role model
so they've watched me over and over
purge go through my things and give to
Goodwill almost weekly so we've done
that many times with their room and
they've definitely learned to give and
gotten very good at it but my first
approach with my daughter especially was
more of frustration at how chaotic her
room was and how she couldn't keep it
clean so I would be upset with her and
say you know you don't deserve these
toys if you can't keep it keep them keep
your room clean
so that of course was not the best
approach so what work really worked for
me and I wanted to share it was that I
came up at it from a place of compassion
so finally I went in her room and I said
Maya you don't deserve this you don't
deserve to be in this place that you can
you can't be happy in you deserve a room
that's clean that is somewhere you can
play and enjoy and somewhere you can
find your toys you really deserve that
and it's so stressful being in a chaotic
environment and I really push that
message and I think it really got us to
where we needed to be
it helped her get rid of even more toys
and the pride on her face day after day
now and when she says to me Mom my room
is did you see it it's still clean and I
can play and I know where things go that
has really solidified the idea and the
message so I wanted to share that my son
is really into Legos and I said that we
can't get anymore because there are just
too many and so I have offered to him to
sell some on eBay if you would like more
you can sell them on eBay and of course
we quickly learned that you do not get
as much for them as you initially paid
so I think he's learning to value his
purchases more and be more intentional
about them hi Josh and Ryan my name is
Laura I saw you at your Minneapolis
event here ah not too long ago I was
living in Chaska paternally since moved
but I have finished listening to a
couple of your episodes and I recently
just finished the budget episode and
that along with one of your events
brought to mind some things for me I'm
30 and until recently didn't have any
debt at all I got through five years of
undergrad bought a car has left on my
own so last over a decade and was able
to get through it all without taking on
a school loans car loans or anything
like that I recently made a decision to
take on a car loan payment
get myself a new car and we'll say that
I regret it but I certainly learned some
things by doing that I put down over
here on the car loan and has been paying
it off and I'm working ahead on that but
although I still have some amount of
debt not nearly as much as others I know
and I am working on taking down because
I've learned that I don't need to have
that car loan where's this most recent
purchase I won't be doing this again
however my call today is more in
reference to the school I was able to
get through five years of school without
taking out any student loans and one of
your earlier callers had called asking
about how she could do that and get to
like Dental Hygienist school and it is
possible and actually looking at going
to PA school shortly and there's an
opportunity for me to get through that
without pulling into any debt it's a
three year program but through service
poor America I can work with them apply
for a scholarship through them I would
have to pay them back a certain way and
if that can certainly be right about on
their website but it's going to
hopefully grant me the opportunity to
fulfill a dream at HACC for a long long
time without taking on any debt
unfortunately because of how our society
is when I tell people I don't have any
debt I'm often called a liar which is
kind of sad but I think it exfoliant to
how we live our life now I just thought
you'd be interested together
thanks so much bye
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
[Music]
you
[Music]